um and I'd like to welcome you to the
third workshop for the program on
data-driven decision processes on
societal considerations and applications
and I want to give a special thanks to
our Workshop organizers today uh we have
shuchi chawla and Irene Lowe and Rachel
Cummings so thank you very much
so you'll have food provided before the
morning talks and in the breaks but for
lunch you're on your own hopefully
you've got a little rain gear I don't
know if it's going to rain today but
please leave food outside the auditorium
and there are lockers on the first floor
on the other side of this partition
where you can leave things if you want
to
um
and our videographer Omid Farr is going
to help speaker set up for their talks
and today's Workshop is hybrid so um
whoever's sharing the session will
monitor the Q a but if you're in the
room you can just raise your hand and
ask a question and finally I want to
give a special thanks to Ashley Hassan
for handling all the logistics for the
workshop including the accommodations
from any of our out-of-town visitors so
I'm going to hand it over to the capable
hands of Irene who will introduce you to
the workshop
thank you well thank you everyone for
being here and for your patience as we
work through the technical difficulties
we are super excited for the program
that we have prepared for this week uh
just to give you a little heads up for
where we're going today we're going to
see a bunch of talks uh generally in the
topic of privacy tomorrow generally in
civic participation and districting and
on Wednesday and Thursday we'll see
talks on fairness interpretability and
applications particularly to health care
so we're really excited for all the
speakers in addition we also have a
couple of you know special afternoon
sessions so today we are going to have a
panel in the afternoon on abridging from
Academia to practice particularly in
public sector and non-profit settings
tomorrow we will have a poster session
where a lot of students and postdocs and
other researchers have submitted some
really exciting posters so we encourage
you to participate you can go upstairs
to the second floor going back to the
panel we will have an opportunity for
people to submit questions so we do ask
that you please submit questions uh to
us ahead of the panel so the panel will
be at four so if you can submit your
questions by about two o'clock that will
be great I'll um shortly after in one of
the breaks put up the email to which you
can submit your questions on the
Whiteboard so just email them in and our
moderate of a key day we'll look at
those ahead of time and select some
tasks
in addition to those we also have a
reception that's happening tonight from
six to seven so we hope that you'll be
able to join us for that that's the one
place where we can all kind of mingle
and chat
oh five to six excuse me uh and we'll
also have um on the last day uh we'll
close out the program with a discussion
and open problem session and so if there
are any topics that you would like to
discuss during that time or any kind of
directions thoughts that you have
sparked
um you know maybe even somewhat concrete
open problems that you want to discuss
feel free to just let us know you can
email us or come find one of the
organizers
okay
um so I think with that I'm going to
welcome up Christina Elemento without
any further Ado to give our first
presentation of the day
oh and just um one moment before we clap
sorry
um for in terms of timing since we are
starting quite late uh what we're going
to do is we're going to eat 15 minutes
into the next break but then we'll
extend the break by about five or ten
minutes so for that break you'll be
you'll have about 20 minute break just
listen for the bill
and so let's welcome Christina
you don't have a microphone
could you let me know if it's working
can you hear me well all right
thank you so much for for the
introduction again I'm Christina levento
I am the product lead for measurement in
the Privacy sandbox at Google
um and I want to say a huge thank you to
the organizers for inviting me uh to
this Workshop
um I find these types of workshops
really energizing the intersection of
industry and Academia it really allows
me to wear both of my hats in one talk
which is very exciting for me
um and what I'm hoping to kind of chat
about for for about the next hour
although Irene please you know wave
hands if I if I need to wrap it up
sooner
um is how we're approaching privacy safe
measurement on the web and some of the
open questions that we're running into
in our work in the in the Privacy
sandbox
so as a quick overview I'll start with
what is the Privacy sandbox why are we
doing this
um and then I want to spend the majority
of the time on some of the measurement
proposals that we have in the Privacy
sandbox
um and as we go through these I'm going
to raise a bunch of open questions uh
this is not a talk where I'm going to
give you really very many answers at all
although I'm happy to take questions in
the talk and clarify anything
um this is really a talk that's intended
to raise some of the places where where
we don't quite know what the right path
forward is where the direction is still
maybe a little unclear or we have goals
that are in conflict with each other or
in tension with each other maybe I
should say instead of conflict
um and I'll wrap up with
um a little bit of cheerleading a little
bit of uh hopefully generating some
excitement for how you can participate
and how you can get involved in privacy
sandbox in and in these types of open
web initiatives I think it's an area
where a lot of people don't realize how
open these processes are how much room
there is for participation from industry
and academics so I'll hopefully wrap up
with with a little bit of of uh
inspiration on on how you can get
involved if you so choose
and I hope you do choose
um all right so with that oh sorry if
you have any questions please do feel
free to raise hands I'm happy to take
questions during the talk
um and if not we'll we'll make sure that
we we leave some time at the end for any
you know questions discussion comments
so please please don't hesitate to
interrupt particularly if any of the the
fun jargon from ad Tech is unclear all
right so let's get started with an
overview of the Privacy sandbox so the
Privacy sandbox
um is uh both for web and Android
although I'll admit my talk today is
going to have a little bit of a bias
towards web that's where where more of
my experience is
um but really what the Privacy sandbox
is is a common Vision to improve user
privacy while sustaining healthy web and
mobile ecosystems and so what this takes
is a collaborative approach with
Publishers Brands ad Tech privacy
Advocates fairness Advocates and others
um and so what is the Privacy sandbox
well the Privacy sandbox is really a set
of common technology proposals across
web and apps for critical advertising
use cases that support the open web
particularly things like ads measurement
and improving ads relevance and as uh
just a quick reminder I work most on the
measurement side so we're going to be
talking largely about measurement today
um although happy to answer questions
about relevance if they come up um or to
kind of point you in the in the right
direction
so uh the Privacy sandbox for the web
right now is available for testing
through Chrome origin trials
um and we expect to have this available
for testing in a beta for Android soon
so I've I've said you know maybe this
feels a little bit corporatey a little
bit like uh here is our motivation for
this wonderful project but really I
think if if you're wondering kind of why
why care about this at all other than
you know it's it's kind of fun to work
on things related to privacy really the
underlying motivation for privacy
sandbox and privacy sandbox started
several years ago was concerns about
cross-site tracking and I expect if
you've heard about privacy sandbox
before it's probably in the context of
chrome deprecating third-party cookies
um but I think it's it's really a
broader Mission than that one of the
challenges that we have with the open
web and some of the underlying
technologies that have powered things
like ads and ads measurement on the open
web is that they allow for pervasive
cross-site tracking they create
persistent identifiers that follow you
across sites that follow you between
apps and what's really challenging is
that the ecosystem has developed a
Reliance in some sense on these
cross-site identifiers so really the way
that I would characterize the Privacy
sandbox is it's trying to break the
Reliance on these persistent identifiers
and instead move us towards
purpose-built privacy preservance
privacy preserving solutions for
critical ads use cases so I'll talk
about kind of two two methods for for
cross-site tracking and we'll get into a
little bit more detail on this in a
couple of slides but really there's kind
of two two big areas that at least that
I think about
so the first are things like third-party
cookies or kind of platform supported
um uh persistent identifiers if you're
not familiar with what a cookie is it's
it's really just a file that's stored in
your web browser and the that file can
be read and written in different
contexts across different sites and what
that allows for is storing a persistent
identifier for a user or potentially
some additional information about them
that can be accessed across different
contexts across different sites so if
you've ever wondered you know how a pair
of shoes can follow you around the
internet it is many times the result of
a third-party cookie but third-party
cookies are not the only way that this
type of tracking can happen covert
tracking so this is things like
fingerprinting is another kind of
challenging uh issue that's that's
cropping up and essentially what this is
is combining pieces of data so perhaps
looking at your IP address combined with
the languages that are installed and
your browser operating or your browser
or your operating system and using that
to kind of create a fingerprint for user
that again still follows them where
they're going on the web which does
still allow kind of this pervasive
cross-site tracking
so really our goal with privacy sandbox
is to introduce new privacy preserving
Technologies and I'm going to talk
primarily about measurement Technologies
today while we phase out third-party
cookies and also work on other proposals
to combat covert tracking so anti-cover
tracking efforts
um so this is not something that you
know Google is doing alone this is not
something that is a you know specific
project that just Google is
participating in this is really an
ecosystem wide effort and our goals
really in the private sandbox are not
just that we get to a more privacy
preserving future but that we get there
in a collaborative way that is balanced
and has room for improvement over time I
don't expect that we're going to go from
today to the perfect future in one
iteration this is going to be something
that we will make compromises along the
way we will make improvements along the
way and really what I'll kind of wrap up
the talk with is is more on this kind of
collaborative nature of the Privacy
sandbox
um the Privacy sandbox is developed in
the open you can see all of our
proposals on GitHub you can comment on
them you can raise issues you can join
us in open calls on the w3c more on
calls every other week at a minimum for
measurement
um so I really I'll wrap up with it with
a bit more detail here but this is an
effort that is not you know one browser
one run browser vendor one operating
system alone is going to push forward
it's something that requires the
participation of the ecosystem
okay so now let's get into the fun stuff
which is the measurement proposals and
I'll raise some open questions here and
um again please please don't hesitate to
interrupt me with questions as they come
up
so let's start with a little bit of
motivation for why measure one kind of
question that is is very natural is okay
these third-party cookie things sound
pretty invasive you know why would any
what legitimate purpose could you
possibly have for these cross-site
identifiers so I'll try you know with a
little bit of of my ads background to
make a case for why measurement is
actually important for for the open web
so why do we measure well advertisers
want to measure because they want to
know that they're spending their money
effectively when you're buying ads you
want to be sure that those ads actually
like fulfilled the purpose that you
bought them for did more people actually
purchase your products because of those
ads were you able to reach the audience
that you wanted to reach even if you're
doing something like a public service
announcement you want to know that you
actually reach the audience that you
were trying to reach
furthermore when we think about the open
web Publishers rely on ad Revenue to
power their sites go ahead
great question so someone's asking what
what does publisher mean and this is a
bad habit I have of using too much
jargon so in this case we mean basically
anybody who's running a site so you can
think about this as a new site uh as a
um a Blog really any anywhere where
you're kind of publishing content where
you're creating content and that's
supported through ads so those
Publishers are relying on being able to
prove that hey the ad slots on my page
are are valuable that this is not
something scammy where the ad isn't even
showing on the page it's something that
actually is I have a relevant audience
for the type of ads that you're trying
to show and the ads that show on my site
are valuable so Publishers rely on this
ad measurement they want to be able to
know an ad showed on my site did it
actually do anything and finally ad text
and uh all uh anticipate the question
here what is an ad Tech this is really
anyone who's providing technology both
as a seller so someone who's actually
helping Publishers to sell their
inventory or a buyer somebody helping
advertisers to actually purchase that
inventory that's available so all these
ad tech companies also want to optimize
and improve their ad performance they're
not interested in showing ads that you
don't actually want to see that you
won't engage with that don't actually
drive value so measurement actually
fulfills kind of like a nice virtuous
cycle here where if you're able to
measure the performance of ads you're
able to actually show better ads and
power more of the open web more
efficiently
so some of the example use cases that we
have in measurement are really you can
kind of boil them down to reporting and
optimization so oftentimes you want to
be able to publish a report you know how
much what type of return that I actually
get on my ad spend so how many dollars
in purchases did I drive and you also
have optimization use cases you want to
actually learn a model to determine what
ads should I show when now the good news
for all of us with with some some
privacy background here is that those
goals are actually really well aligned
with privacy at a fundamental level we
if we set aside the technology that's
used to do this today we're interested
in patterns that are large enough to
actually impact your business decisions
you don't want to change your business
decisions based on one person's behavior
and you would prefer really that your
models be robust outliers you don't want
to learn models that completely depend
on what whether one person purchased an
item after they saw an ad so at a
baseline what I I hope were uh I've
maybe made a somewhat compelling
argument for is that they're good
reasons to measure the performance of
ads to measure ads and those measurement
goals are actually not misaligned with
privacy a lot of what we're trying to do
here can be done in a private fashion
and really the challenge that we're
going to run into is how it works today
what the underlying technology is and
how we can transition that to a more
privacy safe technology going forward
so let's start with a very
oversimplified model of kind of the web
platform and how this might work today
so how this works today is if you have
someone browsing across the web maybe
they are on a publisher site where they
see an ad for a pair of nifty shoes
maybe they click that ad and end up on a
retailer site and then make a purchase
or maybe they just view the ad and they
remember how Nifty that pair of shoes
was a week later and then they go to the
retailer site so how is that measured
today well today that's measured through
a third party cookie so that's that
again that persistent identifier that
every time an ad Tech has for example
JavaScript on a page that cookie is
passed along with a view ping so if you
show an ad and then you ping the ad Tech
server you send a cookie along without
saying hey this was Alice she just saw
an ad when Alice later purchases
something again you can have a
conversion ping or a request is sent
again to the ad Tech server with a
third-party cookie so you're able to
link up that behavior now what's nice
about this is that you can measure a lot
of stuff you can measure uh to a high
degree of fidelity you can get a good
sense of what is going on and now one of
the the challenge of course with that is
that once the cookie kind of leaves the
browser there's a great deal of
enhancement that can happen to that
cookie so it's not just kept within the
scope of your web browser a cookie can
be stored on an ad Tech server or a
third-party server and potentially
matched potentially matched across your
devices potentially matched with your
email and so what this the kind of
challenge that we have here is that well
the initial use case sort of made sense
once you start enriching a third party
with other data sources you can really
start to micro Target and really
aggressively Target people and they've
also fully lost control of the
information about them right if you have
this information living on a server
which is then joined let's say you join
cookies across someone's phone and their
their desktop computer that join is now
out of their control there's not the
thing that they're going to be able to
do to unjoin that so the challenge we
have here is that yes it's nice for ads
measurement but there's also many other
kind of unintended side effects that can
that can happen here
um
I'm surprised someone hasn't asked this
so I'll ask it why don't you just get
rid of them why don't you just get rid
of the third party cookies and the
answer isn't just oh but I'd really like
to measure ads so the answer is that
removing third-party cookies does not
actually solve this problem and so when
we think about what would it what would
happen if we just took third party
cookies away right now turn them off
with no notice well the challenge we'd
have is that there are alternative
identifiers so while third party cookies
are are problematic in the sense that
they can be sent off of the device they
can be linked and enriched with other
information
in some sense they're at least on about
honest about what they were right there
was this cookie that was in your browser
you could have deleted it at some point
um I don't want to claim that you know
somehow a lot of people are doing that
and that they have full control over it
but there was you know at least it was
sort of honest about what it was but one
of the challenges is that like this use
case of needing to measure of wanding
measure doesn't go away if third-party
cookies go away so what can happen is
that alternative identifiers so these
These are actually there are some
proposals for alternative identifiers in
addition to things like fingerprints can
now be used for kind of the the same
purposes now I I would claim that these
are going to have lower Fidelity but at
the same time they're also going to have
even less user control and less
transparency there's going to be less
that we can do about it
okay
hi
[Music]
um I'm not exactly sure how to
articulate my question but go for it I
wanna it seems like there's a tension
between what you've just said and what
you said a second ago which was that uh
measurement the problem of measurement
for ads and what we need to power the ad
ecosystem is it is in line with privacy
if that was true just sort of on its
face
then
there would have been no sort of uh
forcing function over the last 20 years
to develop all this more invasive more
granular micro targeting individualized
tracking
so I I guess
the the the story you've just said is
that if we get rid of third-party
cookies there will be fingerprinting and
if that's true then clearly there's some
you know strong business incentive to
individualize uh tracking in a way that
is incompatible with privacy so how do I
resolve that with what you said a second
ago which was that measurement and
privacy are completely aligned goals
that is a great question and um I I
think you articulated it really well
hopefully everyone also heard the heard
the question on the zoom okay great so I
don't I don't need to repeat it yeah
let's let's not go there this is a great
question so like the the Crux of this
question is if you know measurement is
so great and it's totally fine why would
anybody fingerprint you know what would
you need to do why would you need to do
this so what we'll talk through a little
bit is so if you look at the way that
this system works today
basically what's happening every time a
cookie is leaving the browser is that
there's some log event there's some
event that the ad Tech is storing and
then they're running a matching pipeline
layer across all of those events it's
extremely convenient to do it that way
right you don't need to know what you're
Measuring Up Front you don't need to
think about this you just slurp up
everything and then you deal with it
later
so while I would argue that the
measurement goals are well aligned with
privacy we all have the human tendency
to push it a little too far and
particularly on the targeting side that
can go quite a bit too far on the
measurement side I'll give a couple of
examples of this and these are some
pieces of feedback that that I've gotten
from people in the ad Technica system I
need to be able to report to my
customers the exact number of
conversions driven by ads per hour
why unless it's Black Friday why are you
doing that what it what is the actual
purpose of that and a lot of it can be
because my boss has gotten really used
to me being able to do that because I've
been able to do that in patch was a
statistically meaningful absolutely not
unless something's broken in which case
you've got better ways of detecting if
something is broken but the part of the
challenge here is that because we have
been able to measure unlimited amounts
all of the time we've gotten a little
bit kind of dependent on being able to
do this in a somewhat lazy fashion
instead of thinking in advance about
what is it that we're really trying to
measure what really are goals I would
argue that that has introduced an
efficiency into into ads it actually has
not made ads better to be able to kind
of
turn back and forth between different
strategies but it is a great question
and I think it also speaks to kind of
this this ecosystem concern of hey
there's clearly demand for this there's
clear need for it how is it that you
know even if we do think it's aligned
with privacy even if we do think we can
do this in a responsible fashion how are
we going to move an ecosystem along with
us it's a great question and I'll I'll
come back to it again a couple of times
in the talk
hi thanks um do you mind going to the
next slide so I I think I'm possibly the
least technologically Adept person at
Simon so I just want to understand so
these things that you describe to what
extent are they sort of in control of
say Chrome or you know my operating
system so what I mean is could Google in
principle stop
um you know maybe third-party apps from
using any of these things
um if they wanted to so I use Brave
which I'm told by my very
technologically Adept colleagues is
really cool and I sort of think they
they presumably deal with not just
cookies but maybe other stuff like that
but sort of to what extent you know you
have control over these things and to
what extent you don't really is the
question this is an excellent question
and this comes back to kind of
anti-covert tracking efforts so I'll
give one example of something that it's
it's rather hard to get rid of which
would be an IP address
if I'm going to be sending packets
across the internet I do I do sort of
need to know where they're going now
vpns can help with this there are other
ways that you can try to kind of pool IP
addresses together but a number of these
signals you know the languages that you
have installed let's say are kind of
important if you need to actually
display something in the correct
language the fonts things like that now
does that mean every web request should
be a complete free-for-all where all of
that information is sent all the time
probably not and there we do have a
proposal for kind of saying hey really
only request this stuff when you need it
so there is certainly a very important
sister body of work going on right now
to try to kind of plug some of these
fingerprinting holes I strongly suspect
that this is going to be a long-term
challenge that there are likely to be
many things that we actually do want to
be kind of interesting and unique about
different different people's machines
but I it that doesn't mean it's
completely hopeless it doesn't mean we
can't make progress I think we can
and actually I'll come back to this in
the end of the talk which is that a lot
of these questions really kind of come
down to sequencing because well I've
talked about bad things that can happen
with fingerprinting there are some good
things too very likely your credit card
company uses this to know is it really
your device or is this some other person
who's actually trying to impersonate you
so it's not 100 bad 100 of the time
there are some spam and fraud use cases
that take advantage of this existing as
well and I think aloni's question is
really very prescient here hey like
why why why would you have all this
stuff if it's really so evil the
challenges there are very legitimate
uses for this type of fingerprinting as
well as third party cookies so the
challenge that we have really is can we
come up with suitable alternatives for
these legitimate use cases in a way that
is responsible and doesn't get us into
into too much of a bind
um so hopefully that helps and and we'll
come back to this later but but please
do do bring it up again
um hello I have a question that maybe is
uh very obvious to sort of privacy
people but can you just elaborate a
little bit more on like the the harms of
the status quo is it that like if you're
collecting very granular data on
everything you're very susceptible to
data breaches like can you just
elaborate that on a little bit a little
bit what a great question and I strongly
suspect in some of the the talks
unfairness later this week uh someone
will give a more eloquent answer it than
I'm about to give
um so
maybe let me give an example of cross
device
you have maybe a work phone a phone
that's provided by your work you have a
personal computer and let's imagine you
make the mistake of you know signing
into a site once on your work phone with
your personal email account
someone can now match these two devices
together they know they both belong to
you
who has access to that
do you know are you sure probably you
don't um and the the challenges that a
lot of this can be bought and sold so a
lot of this type of data can end up in
places you did not expect it to end up
and that is really the challenge with
these persistent identifiers making it
out of the device right one is once it
is sitting in someone's third-party
server somewhere it is very challenging
to claw that back and it is very easy to
link that up with other data sets so
really I would say that the primary
concern here Beyond you know I think we
could certainly talk about the the harms
of kind of micro targeted advertising uh
I I'm not the most qualified to speak on
that but
I think to to me really the biggest
concern here is that you have this
really juicy way of linking up someone's
Behavior potentially across many devices
in a way that they have limited
visibility into and control over
um so that really puts puts the consumer
puts the user at it as a substantial
disadvantage when someone comes back
later and says well you know maybe your
credit score should be lower because I
see that you have this other device
where you did this type of browsing
um you're not going to have great
visibility into that that can be
potentially very challenging
great question
all right so these are excellent
questions but thank you for asking them
um I think where we had sort of left off
was hey if we get rid of these
third-party cookies we're gonna have it
we're gonna have a tough time
claiming that somehow we we did some
amazing thing for for privacy all on its
own if the whole ecosystem then just
turns to fingerprinting so what are we
thinking about doing in the Privacy
sandbox so what we're thinking about are
purpose-built platform API is to solve
some of these use cases
um I'm primarily going to talk about
measurement but there are also proposals
for spam and abuse for relevance for
things like Federated login and you can
find all of that on on privacy
sandbox.com we have links for all of
those proposals
um and largely what we're planning what
we're kind of proposing to do here is
instead of having a cookie having a
persistent identifier leave the device
with every interaction with an ad with
every conversion instead we're proposing
to do Platform mediated measurement
where we're linking up those events on
the device so let's look at this in a
little bit more detail I'm going to talk
specifically about attribution reporting
today so that's attributing conversions
to ads that the previous the user
previously saw so essentially how this
works is that when a user sees an ad or
clicks an ad on a publisher life the ad
Tech so whoever serves the ad is going
to register that event with a browser
they're going to say hey dear browser I
just served up an ad here's some
information about it later if the user
actually engages with that Advertiser
site maybe they make a purchase the ad
Tech again is going to register
conversion with a browser and say hey
browser I just saw a conversion that
might be relevant to one of my
advertisers I don't know if I've shown a
nod before but if I have please match it
then what the browser is going to do is
actually take care of that matching and
report that back to the advertiser with
delays with noise added basically with a
layer of privacy protections included
and with rate limits there are limits
here to help provide information about
how well are the ads performing but not
just handing over everything all the
time with a persistent identifier
so in this API we actually have two
different report types and this is where
a lot of our open sessions will come in
so we have event level reporting this is
being able to say here's a specific ad
event did it convert or not with some
noise so very coarse conversion
information it's not the whole purchase
value everything about that conversion
but kind of a course noisy signal on did
it convert or not as well as summary
reporting which is kind of thinking
about larger slices but providing
potentially more detail so perhaps a
total purchase value for a campaign or a
campaign in a particular geography
so let's have a I have a quick look at
event level reports before I raise some
some open questions on it
um for I I realize we have kind of a mix
of folks in the audience so none of the
specific things are terribly important
on this slide it's really the flow here
that matters so
um what the flow that essentially
happens here is when there is an ad
interaction to an ad view or a click the
ad Tech is going to register a source
and in the source they're going to
include an event ID
so this guy here is an event ID that's
assumed to be a unique event ID and
they'll tell us how long they actually
want to want this to stick around this
is in seconds and I can't remember how
long I made this for I think maybe two
weeks
um and then when a conversion happens
they will register a trigger so they'll
do a trigger registration to say hey
this thing converted and maybe it was a
purchase conversion type so there's a
very coarse conversion type with some
trigger data I am glossing over many
details that we try to provide to add
text to let them prioritize different
conversions but essentially what this
turns into
is a report that is sent back to the
advertiser with the same event ID
um and the trigger data but the trigger
data is noise so this whole report is
actually run through randomized response
this whole thing is randomized response
um and I can't remember the order of my
slides uh okay so before we get into
randomized response I'll give a quick
refresher on differential privacy I'm
expecting we have a mix of half and half
on people who are like move on Christina
and people who have not maybe not seen
this before so differential privacy is a
mathematically rigorous foundation for
private data analysis and essentially
what DP is is it basically says if
you're going to run a mechanism on some
private data it had better be the case
that the probability of any outcome of
that mechanism does not change too much
if one person changes their data within
the database or if one person is added
or removed and one thing that it is
worth kind of looking at
um and very fortuitously I had already
bolded adjacent databases we're going to
talk a lot about adjacency and what
adjacency makes sense for these use
cases often we think about a person in
or out
in some cases we're going to be thinking
about an event in or out is that
acceptable that so that's an open
question I want to pose but randomized
response if you're not familiar is is a
differentially private mechanism and
essentially the way that it works is
we're going to provide plausible
deniability
to whoever is responding to this if they
have a single yes or no answer we're
going to provide them plausible
reliability by asking them to flip a
coin if its heads are going to tell us
the truth if its tails are going to flip
a second coin and tell us the result of
that coin coin flip heads for yes tails
for no so
um what's nice about this is while
randomized response is very simple it's
nice to explain to people they kind of
get oh yeah it's you know 50 probability
this is just the outcome of a coin flip
intuitively it's nice to explain
it's also relatively straightforward to
extend this to different privacy
parameters if you don't want a Fair coin
flip you want to bias that coin flip and
you can also extend it to larger outcome
spaces which is in fact what we will
need to do for our purposes so when we
randomize response this attribution
report we're looking at the entire
outcome space of all of the the trigger
data that we could have provided which
can mean no trigger data that no trigger
happened so every time an ad Tech is
actually registering a source with us we
are flipping coins in the background to
say hey should we tender conversion
happened so what's nice about this is
that we we do have actually the right
structure in place to provide some
pretty reasonable privacy protections
but beyond that kind of hey we could
make this DP with nice perimeters aspect
of this there are some very nice
structural limits that come along with
this proposal there's no cross-site
identifier there's no I identifier that
is shared across sites that sent to
multiple places there's an event ID only
and that's only on one of the sites
for views we provide at most one bit of
metadata and one conversion per view so
compared with today where you can
measure an unlimited amount of metadata
for an unlimited number of conversions
basically forever now you only get at
most one bit of metadata one conversion
um for a more brief period of time yeah
Rachel
um what is the one bit that you get is
it whether it was shown or not excellent
question so you both so one way to think
about this is is it's really two bits
it's did it convert or not and then it
conditioned on it converting you get one
bit of metadata so what I suspect most
ad texts will end up using is was this a
purchase or was this some other kind of
positive signal in the funnel that the
the uh person was moving towards a
purchase
yes that's a great question and really
we are trying to leave the the choice of
the metadata up to the ad Tech this is
not something that that the platform is
really dictating so for views one bit of
metadata one conversion for clicks three
bits of metadata three conversion so
substantially more information for
clicks still much more limited than
third-party cookies but in this case
there was actually a user gesture the
user did in fact say hey like I saw this
ad and cared about it enough to click on
it which is a substantially better
signal there's much more kind of natural
rate limits that come along with clicks
versus ad views you might have scrolled
that ad had didn't even process it at
all so there are different limits there
we also have uh there's a question from
the zoom yeah um the question is does
all this assume the user is not
regularly clearing cookies and history
that's a great question so
um
both for attribution reporting are our
API proposal as well as cookies you can
clear your your browsing history you can
clear your cookies and the same is true
for the for the type of data that we're
storing here so if you were to let's say
visit a site and a source was registered
and then you cleared that site data that
that Source would go away in the same
way that a third-party cookie would go
away
I hope that answers the question but but
if not we we can certainly come back to
a follow-up
um and I I do think it's it's important
to remember that that most consumers uh
I mean the the joke that we kind of have
on our team is you know on Thursdays we
clear our browser history that that
doesn't tend to be like a common you
know consumer pattern
so
um right so really the the nice thing
that we have about these net level
reports is there are some nice
structural benefits in addition to the
potential for adding noise potential for
adding enough noise to to have kind of
more meaningful privacy protections
now
to a Looney's early question are these
useful is this worth doing is this
enough information or would someone just
fingerprint anyway well there are a
couple of you know good signals and bad
signals here so first
um what's really nice about this is when
you think about having an event ID you
can go ahead and store that event ID in
your logs as an ad Tech and do later
exploratory analysis if you don't know
which features you're thinking about for
your ml model yet that's fine you didn't
have to know them at source registration
time as long as you log them properly
you could do this exploratory analysis
later so it's it's very nice in that
sense it kind of matches this existing
way that people tend to think about
having logs having event IDs processing
them later so it fits very nicely with
that so in that sense it's quite useful
um and the other thing that we do here
is that we're splitting privacy budgets
per ad Tech to kind of prevent any sort
of interference so when you think you're
measuring something you are in fact
probably measuring it it's very unlikely
that somebody else can interfere in a
way that would would mess up your
measurement
um uh module of course that the user
clears their data they cleared their
data
challenges some of the challenges that
we've heard are adapting systems delayed
conversions so what should I do if my
pipelines today are assuming that every
time a user is really converting I'm
getting that Real Time versus delays on
the order of several days potentially on
the order of several hours
so that is that is certainly a practical
challenge as well as noise correction
methods while all measurement today is
noisy you know clearing history is a
great example of an introduction of
noise it tends to be noise that we try
to ignore and pretend doesn't exist or
we model like in very general terms
whereas in this case we're telling you
this is exactly the noise that we
applied here's how you should correct it
that's a very kind of different way of
thinking about data collection and if
you're curious to see kind of more
feedback that we've gotten on these
proposals um you can see it on purpose
to inbox or sorry this is
developer.chrome privacy inbox feedback
there's this great place on the internet
where you can search for these terms and
it will come up but we do provide
quarterly summaries of all of this
feedback so if you're curious to kind of
hear more about how this has been going
um there are a bunch of open questions
here so the Privacy bar what notion of
adjacency should we be using right now
we think about this from an event level
perspective we think about
you know for this particular ad event am
I giving plausible deniability whether
whether it converted or not and in
conjunction with rate limits that's you
know probably helping quite a bit but
it's not the same thing as what we might
intuitively think about when we think
about user level privacy guarantees
furthermore this happens over time this
may happen many times for a particular
user even for a particular publisher and
Advertiser pair so what is the right
privacy bar what are the right
parameters how should we think about
parameters when in the worst case
everything is the same how do we think
about reasoning in in those spaces where
we know we want to do better
um but it's it can sometimes be
challenging to reason about things when
worst case kind of looks the same
um there's also a lot of kind of
interesting problem structure here event
IDs are extremely convenient right we
talked about how it's nice to log those
but they also make it impossible to just
apply shuffling and get any privacy
amplification straight out the box which
is somewhat disappointing right you
might hope that because there are many
ads being shown that you could actually
really take advantage of scale here this
is something to help you but it doesn't
quite fit with the way we've got the
problem structured today
there are also a lot of interactions
between different parameters priority in
in the API that makes it challenging
every time someone makes a feature
request to us we have to think through
very carefully how this impacts and
interact with all those different
features so it's not something that is
quite always straightforward to reason
about how a given request will impact
the Privacy properties of of the API
sorry I lost track of requests here is
that request for absolute request so we
we talked about this in public
um so often we'll we'll get requests
from from ad tax let's say
um it was a recent one
um a reason one supporting multiple
domains so if you have uh let's say you
have an Advertiser that has my
Advertiser black friday.com and my
advertiser.com and you want to be able
to track conversions across both of
those domains so those types of requests
you know is
[Music]
requests come up frequently um
particularly when you have systems that
are already built today that you're
trying to retrofit there are a lot of
these corporate cases that come up there
are a lot of these requests that you
know on the face of them it's it's not
an ad Tech saying hey can can you just
give me all of the information right now
they're making actually a very
legitimately structured request they're
not trying to to like get away with
anything it is but it's genuinely
challenging for us to raise about how
that to interact with others I think I'm
quite a bit behind where I wanted to be
a time-wise so I wanted to speed up just
a tad
um and talk about aggregatable reports
so we just talked about event level but
not everything needs to be at the event
level we have a pretty strict rate
limits on event level so in aggregate
you might also want to be able to
basically produce tables like this you
want to be able to say hey for campaign
one two three four how many purchases
did I get how many add to carts did I
get you might also want to do geography
breakdowns and what we allow you to do
is actually register in your source and
your trigger pieces of keys that allow
you to build up you know perhaps this is
uh campaign one two three four and this
is category shirts and let you build up
these keys and actually do aggregated
counts one of the interesting things
here that we have is that instead of
doing all this privacy accounting
outside of the device
all of the kind of contribution bounding
of making sure that you can't register
too many reports for any given user for
any given ad event is actually done on
the device so this kind of these cryptic
values of you know why would you add 32
000 to a campaign count that's actually
a scaled contribution so we give you um
I think 65 000 basically sensitivity
units for each uh individual ad event
and you can spend those basically in any
way you like across all of the the
different things that you'd like to
measure now as a spoiler alert this is
really complicated for for ad techs we
have not gotten overwhelmingly oh my
gosh this is so simple and I know
exactly what to do feedback it tends to
be an area where there's a lot of
questions understandably because this is
thinking about the problem in a very
different way than you do it today so I
think to eloni's question earlier
even if you can do a good job with this
this is very different than how you
think about doing ads measurement today
this is a substantial shift in the way
that you think about like what your data
model is supposed to be when you have to
dictate it and how you think about
measuring different goals so essentially
what these reports look like they're
encrypted and we send that batch of and
we send encrypted reports back to the ad
Tech the ad Tech then batches those
reports and processes them in a way
where we are are adding the appropriate
amount of noise and because we did all
that contribution bounding on browser we
basically get to add a constant amount
of noise instead of having to do any
fancy accounting off off the device
which turns out to be both uh convenient
and sometimes frustrating
um
I'm going to skip over a LaPlace I'm
going to assume that if you've uh if you
are here I'm seeing some nods okay so
we're using essentially LaPlace noise
for for adding noise here
um so what's nice about this again no
cross site ID there's there's no kind of
persistent identifier that's being used
for the user
um and you have this really we have this
nice classic setting of I'm adding noise
to Aggregates that's actually something
we know how to do and again we have a
lot of these these structural limits in
place now of course part of the
challenge here
um is that while you can get high
accuracy reports
um it's very different than the way that
you you do it today so you can get high
accuracy reports you can get like very
expressive things like return on ad
spend it's possible to do that in this
model there's a great deal of
flexibility but it's not something that
is intuitively obvious to most ad techs
how to take advantage of it and there
are some legitimate challenges that come
up with with the way that we do this one
of the main key Discovery so imagine
that you would like to count conversions
per or publisher and so you include a
publisher website a URL basically in
your aggregation keys
how do you figure out which of those
URLs you're going to ask for accounts
for
that that can actually be somewhat
challenging because it's not like
everyone all the ad techs have like a
list of all the Publishers where they
they show ads and it's only those
Publishers on the list it tends to much
more Dynamic than that so there are some
legitimate challenges that they come up
here in addition to the kind of
substantial shift from current practice
um so I think uh I'll go ahead and skip
this to get on to the even more open
questions because I think this is a bit
broader
um so really a lot of the open questions
that come up in these proposals are how
do we reason about these structural
protections like a 30-day limit three
conversions per click versus the more
formal privacy protections I'm running
randomized response what Epsilon did I
use how do we think about the
interaction between those things how do
we reason about kind of formal
definitions when the worst case in the
formal definition is actually really bad
and as a spoiler alert if you have IP
addresses coming along with your
encrypted reports
your formal privacy parameter is pretty
bad unless you're going to somehow be
very confident that the ad Tech didn't
look at any IP addresses so there's
going to be a lot of challenges here
where the structure can be quite good we
can have made a substantial step forward
from third-party cookies but we're not
quite there in terms of being able to
argue the whole system end to end is DP
with a really small Epsilon right like
that that's not realistically where
where we are today and likely not where
we're going to be in in the short term
um another challenge there is you know
particularly once you're in this setting
where your maybe your Epsilon is not
great you start to get an avalanche of
feature request and if your Epsilon is
you know already pretty bad how much
worse is it if you just you know make it
a little bit worse and you end up in
kind of this interesting question of you
have to reason about privacy versus
utility versus usability like it isn't
even you know I get bad results it's
just I can't even use the thing unless
you you give me some different feature
um and thinking about things like
debugging fraud detection a lot of these
are not going to play nice with formal
definitions of privacy you will need
something that says hey
this is crashing or I'm getting really
funky results at an important time of
year
I need to figure out what the heck is
going on I have to be able to like break
this thing open and see what's happened
so it becomes a very challenging setting
to work in because at the same time you
want to kind of hold this privacy bar
but at the same time you are really
trying to make sure that you don't then
make it so private that it becomes
useless or so private that it competes
very poorly with or or it seems on the
face of it to compete very poorly with
with things like fingerprinting
so it can be a very challenging setting
to to work in and certainly an area
where I think more input from the
broader privacy Community can be really
helpful to kind of make sure that we're
keeping ourselves honest
um while not letting kind of the the
perfect become the enemy of the good
um there are also questions about
underlying technology choices but I
think given the the kind of the focus of
this Workshop there's also really a
question about how these Solutions can
enable transparency and who they should
enable transparency to so if you think
about third-party cookies maybe you can
tell that a third party city was
accessed but you have no idea what's in
it and you don't know what happened to
it after the device on the flip side if
you have a platform API
there is potentially a lot more vehicle
for transparency there than you might
have had with third-party cookie right
this is an API for attribution reporting
it has a structured notion of a source
and a trigger you know how many reports
were sent so there is great potential
for transparency I don't want to kid
anybody into thinking that somehow
you're going to show that report to a
consumer and they're going to make an
informed choice about whether they want
to keep this API on right like it's it's
something where yes we can provide
transparency and certainly in in
relevance use cases where you might have
a topics taxonomy which is actually
human readable that may make more sense
to have that transparency to the
consumer to the end user for cases like
measurement which are very pervasive
transparency can be helpful but helpful
to whom how should we make this
available and how how can we help kind
of enforce some Norms about what level
of measurement is or is not acceptable
okay so I I'm at about uh the five
minutes remaining Mark I think so I want
to make a pitch uh for for participating
um so I I know that I've just talked
about a lot of challenges of platform
Solutions and how hard it is to make all
this stuff work and that's certainly
true but I am fundamentally optimistic
about platform-based Solutions
particularly for measurement for a
couple of reasons
um a big one being transparency
um it would be very nice as an ad Tech
to be able to say hey I am using this
platform solution which has these
transparency properties so leave me
alone like I'm privacy safe like please
don't come like asking me for a bunch of
additional data like as long as you're
genuinely doing that and you're
operating in good faith it would be very
nice to be able to say kind of something
simple it would be very nice to be able
to simulate how can things actually
impact people rather than kind of
knowing something bad could be happening
but I don't really know what
consistency
um there is you know one of the the
challenges and kind of one of the
downsides of fingerprinting is it's
probabilistic and you have no ground
truth or you have very limited ground
truth very biased ground truth so I
would argue
um that when you think about how well
fingerprinting Solutions are going to
work on Black Friday or on whatever
particular holiday of the year or
weekend of the year is important to you
your prior observations may have
absolutely no power under in that
important setting but if you have people
kind of churning what devices they're
using at a particular time of year if
you have different Behavior people are
on different networks at critical times
you you may or may not be able to
actually accurately model these things
so you have this challenge with
fingerprinting where there really is no
underlying ground truth so how are you
going to convince anybody that your
stats are legit if you have on the other
hand a platform provided solution you do
have much better sense of consistency
particularly for things like app to web
measurement um which we we haven't
talked about in detail but I'm happy to
chat about in The Break
um if you want to know I showed an ad in
an app and then someone went and
purchased it on the web today that's
done through kind of you know cookie
matches it's done through a lot of
offline matching If instead that's
mediated by the platform obviously with
trade-offs with controls that go along
with it you know when that was available
you actually know your recall for app to
web which would be a substantial
improvement over the status quo and
finally
um there's durability right instead of
playing whack-a-mole as kind of
anti-cover tracking measures come online
from different browsers from different
os's instead you have something that's
kind of built to work and intended to
work you're using it for its intended
purpose so you have some kind of
confidence and durability
so what I really want to encourage
everyone here is is to join in this
conversation all of these proposals are
open you can see all of them on GitHub
um you too can be famous on GitHub if
you would like to comment on on these
proposals
um and there there really is uh there
has been great uh participation so far
uh I you know can can walk you through
all of our fun stats and fun colors
um but these proposals have really been
shaped by and continue to be shaped by
public feedback public input
um so I if if nothing else if you take
really nothing else away from this talk
um I would encourage you to go look at
these proposals whether you care more
about relevance anti-cover tracking
measurement
um they're all out there and are really
open to feedback and open to influence
on on the direction
um so uh with that I'll wrap it up and
uh take any questions if we have any
remaining time
five minutes for questions please wait
for the microphone if you have a
question here or also on Zoom you can
ask questions in the Q a
so I I should probably confess I'm an
economist which is what we're trying to
explain the question I'm about to ask so
the the way you sort of pitch this is um
you know we collect too much data now
and we're serving these ads and we want
to collect less data and continue
serving the ads and of course by
targeting ads better we increase what we
call consumer surplus right so you know
I can buy hopefully you know things that
I want and that you know improves
people's lives how do you think about
the costs kind of rigorously of
collecting more data so in particular
there was nothing in your talk that sort
of suggested that in fact you know less
of less data collection is better in
some kind of
principled evaluated way right so you
you obviously mentioned some reasons for
why I do want to collect data uh uh
which is so it's a fraud prevention
right but that's something that's
quantifiable what about sort of other
ways in which you might you know what
what how do you kind of as a company I
guess think about of both private and
societal costs of data correction
of kind of um ad revenue or or consumer
surplus or something like that uh this
is a great PM interview question I might
feel it um so I think that you know the
Crux of the question is if if you had to
put a dollar number on like how what is
the benefit of privacy
um how would you do that and and it's a
very challenging question and I think
you know I would personally argue that
that is a slippery slope to go down
um because to a large extent a lot of
the concerns about privacy do end up
to some extent boiling down to concerns
about fairness so there's both the sense
of wow this is really creepy I'm being
followed all over the web and it makes
me uncomfortable it makes me less
willing to go browse the web in an open
fashion like it makes me less willing to
go to different publisher sites so
certainly there is a dollar cost I'm not
entirely sure how you would measure that
on the this is creepy so I don't want to
do it so I end up concentrating my
activity in Wild Gardens where I end up
concentrating my activity in places that
are not open that are not supporting a
broad variety of perspectives
um I think the second piece would be
kind of a fairness concern which again
you know there is a cost it's probably
more of a long-term cost than a
short-term dollar cost where if you have
um kind of hyper uh micro targeted ads
if you're able to kind of specifically
figure out well this person's willing to
pay this much so that's what I'm gonna
going to try to charge them or this
person is desperate for this thing
um that that that can be very
problematic so from from my perspective
the way I would kind of personally think
through this is we have uh kind of the
do we want to preserve the open web do
we want to preserve open ecosystems and
I would argue that yes we do and that
benefits us as a society whether we put
a dollar number on it or whether that
dollar number is something that would
manifest in the short term or over a
very long term
um is is I think Up For Debate
um but there there is inherent value to
these open ecosystems and there is
inherent value to kind of being able to
to roam without fear
um I I don't know how I would put a cost
on someone being afraid to browse a site
with medical information because they're
worried that then they're going to start
seeing the ads for that thing somewhere
else or they're worried that that's
going to follow them around I don't know
how to put a dollar number on that but
to me it does seem seem valuable
foreign
can you elaborate a little bit on uh
this sort of uh technical problem uh
publisher or Advertiser would face in
having a privacy budget for these
summary reports for example so how how
should one you know if I were uh if I
wanted to you know optimize some system
how should I think of privacy budgets
what sort of constraint is that yeah
it's in this is a great question
um so there are a couple of ways this
can manifest one of the the big ones is
how many third parties do I work with
right I might be working with several ad
techs and several third parties to try
to measure across the the scope of all
of the ads that I'm running so that
becomes immediately challenging right
like how do I split that up to a large
extent we've dodged that by providing
separate budgets is that great for
privacy uh I'm not going to argue that
it is um but it does help in terms of
that measurement consistency but other
challenges you can run into are I think
um a sense of I used to be able to
measure everything I used to be able to
look at my entire funnel over a very
very long period of time where I could
really follow a person all the way
through their Journey let's say for
purchasing insurance which is not
necessarily something that you do super
quickly but it's very high value or
purchasing tax software so I think the
challenge that you have here is really
thinking about your goals as a company
versus your goals of each campaign that
you run right as an Advertiser you might
have a upper funnel brand campaign just
trying to help people know that you
exist then you may have a much more
targeted event campaign or a campaign
that's targeted for kind of a specific
segment of users and what you may have
thought about in the past is kind of
because it was the all-you-can-eat
buffet you measure each one of these
separately they can all have their
separate goals there and there's no
competition between them like the only
competition between them was for Budget
dollars which by the way they fought it
out using their measurement results so
they're all used to kind of needing
those results to make that case so I
think it really is
um the biggest challenge is thinking
holistically about your goals as an
organization and how you structure your
budget that way and I don't know that
there is a simple or easy answer to that
right if like how you should measure
brand versus performance advertising
when you're when you're privacy budget
constrained I think would be a very
interesting open question
um for For What the right way to think
about those two very different goals are
and how to kind of allocate your your
budget between them
so the time for questions let's thank
our speaker
[Applause]
back in about 20 minutes